[Music]
[Applause]
joe burrow the bengals quarterback led
the bengals to the win against the
vikings 20-27 threw for a couple of
touchdowns including one to his former
teammate jamar chase as they pick up the
victory in overtime congratulations joe
how do you feel today
good to start the season off of the win
especially
the way we won we you know faced some
adversity and came out on top that's
something we weren't able to do last
year so it's good you could win like
that i uh take me into overtime fourth
and one you have the ball you own 48
there's 39 seconds to go
in the third quarter you had a fourth
and one you ran the ball
what's the conversation like with that
play call
to keep the drive alive
hey we're gonna put the ball in my hands
um
you know i saw a look from the defense
that
you know i think opened up the play that
we had um so we got to that play and
you know it was uh it wasn't didn't work
out the way we expected it to but we got
the job done wait but you go to the line
of scrimmage
are is the play called going to be a
running call
uh yes yeah it is and then you see
something and then you realize that hey
i got an option here and i can hit my
tight end
yeah they put
basically 3d line or they put a
d-lineman over the center and then two
d-linemen in the a-gaps and so i knew it
was going to be tough to run the ball
so we just got to a pass and executed it
how much fun is it to uh
well take me back to the play in the
huddle call what what is the play that
you threw to jamar for his first nfl
touchdown
uh just double go why shallow um
just tell jamar to run as fast as you
can
i thought i'm gonna throw it up to you
okay
so did you say jamar just run as fast as
you can i'll throw it up to you
that was understood
explain this whole the college football
to the nfl football and jamar was not
able to pick it up i mean i i understand
it but it sort of came out i'd never
heard it before from a wide receiver
well
i think
jamar is an honest guy and he's been
having some struggles um
basically just in the preseason games
you know he's been playing really well
in practice
and
you know the nfl football is different
uh i don't know how big of a party was
playing in the drops he was having in
the preseason but
you know there's no doubt in my mind
he's gonna show up ready to play
game one and he sure did you know people
were asking me what what i think he was
gonna look like yesterday and
i told everyone just don't worry about
jamar all right he's gonna show up on
game day and do his thing and that's
exactly what he did
how much do you think of your uh your
offseason with your surgeries with uh
your knee
no i've put in the work to not think
about the knee at all um you know i got
got rolled up got hit on it yesterday
and you know felt great so that was
exciting for me you put that behind us
and we can move on
what was the worst day for you
worst day
for in the rehab
yeah i mean those first couple days
after surgery were pretty excruciating
you know there's a lot of a lot of
damage in there a lot of trauma
and so those first couple days after
surgery basically any kind of movement
was
excruciating pain so that was not very
fun but
we got out of that fairly quickly after
about a week and then it was smooth
sailing
bears played the rams last night how
much of that game did you watch since
your next game is uh against the bears
yeah i watched all of it you know they
obviously have some some really good
players on defense you know the rams
played really well they got some rams
are loaded um and i have to
you're going to have to to bring some of
that next week i'm excited to to go into
chicago i think that'll be a fun road
game um
and they're they're talented on defense
we're going to show up to play
is the game slowing down
college quarterbacks are you know uh
relatively new quarterbacks in the nfl
talk about usually year two it starts to
slow down a little bit you're able to
kind of see things differently has that
happened to you
yeah i think
you know
right before i got hurt last year it was
really starting to to click for me and
slowing down
um and then i got hurt and wasn't able
to
really show that the last part of the
season um so you know
i feel really comfortable back there
yesterday and we had a great plan going
in ran the ball well defense played
great i think it was a great team win
what advice would you give a rookie
quarterback
um don't be afraid to make mistakes
you know go out there and play your game
you know if you see it throw let it rip
and then you know talk about it later
but
you know when i got in trouble was when
i was
indecisive and
you know slow and
wasn't really sure what i wanted to do
and when i just went out there and let
it rip you know we i played pretty well
are you on social media
yeah i'm back on there
i'm not
not a big twitter guy but i'm on
instagram it's dangerous joe
it is it really is that's why i'm not on
twitter
because
you know twitter they can get to you
you know every little thing you get you
see
instagram you're kind of in your own
little world you don't have to look at
all that stuff
were you on twitter last year
um i mean a little bit not too much but
twitter yeah twitter's a
not a
not a very positive place
how did they rough you up what were some
of the things that were said
oh i mean you hear it all
i mean bust
weak arm
terrible i mean all the above you hear
it all on twitter
instagram's a little more positive is
that what you're saying
yeah you know i think everyone has a
positive mindset on there yeah if you
could change one rule in the nfl
that that uh you had in college is is
there a rule that you would love to
change
now that's a good question um
i would like for there to be less tv
timeouts
yeah no it feels like
every series you're running out there
and waiting for four minutes before you
start to play really
feels like uh i don't know that feels
just like you take a long time to
to get out there and call the play
what do you talk about when you're out
there waiting for the you know the game
to start or continue resume well you
know
you hear zach in the headset you know
going through his thought process on on
what play to call
and going through his pros his thought
process as far as you know what my job
is on that play and then he relays what
he wants me to tell some of the guys in
the huddle as far as what pertains to
their jobs and then also you just
you know kind of a little fun out there
talk about whatever you know you don't
want it to get too serious
uh did you want to talk about the lsu
tigers
yeah sure i was talking about segments
did you watch the ucla game
i did yeah i did yeah yeah yeah that was
a tough one um but
you know i think they got a great
coaching staff but it'll they'll get
that right yeah and it seemed like the
physicality was lacking lacking a little
bit and if i know coach oh that's not
going to last very long
does ohio state's loss affect you at all
um no i don't i don't i
you know i haven't played with
you know last year even last year i had
some guys on the team that i played with
so i was still i was rooting for them um
but no it doesn't affect me too much i
still talk to
some of the coaches there so i still
have some relationships on the team but
i wouldn't say it affected me
well it's great to talk to you and i
mean you talked to urban meyer about
giving trevor lawrence advice was that
during the off season yeah i mean
coach meyer stay in contact um you know
we're good friends now
so
we talk
we talk on and off you know every couple
weeks he just checks in you know he's a
good guy good coach and i'm excited to
play against him week four though wait
so you're friends with him now you said
yeah yeah
but you weren't friends with him
well i mean he was my coach you know he
was hard on me um
but no now that you know we've kind of
got away from it from a lot for a while
you know we're we're good friends we
talk a lot
about a lot of different things football
life
all that good stuff does he make you
laugh is he funny
yeah yeah he's
he's hilarious in his own way
yeah but i keep hearing that about nick
saban and bill belichick but i never see
it
well i don't think they want you to see
that oh okay yeah but they're doing a
good job of that joe
[Laughter]
uh hey congrats on the win good luck
against uh the bears and uh you know
maybe uh justin fields will be getting a
little more air time for the bears with
this game
yeah you know he's a good player
he was
you know the three plays he got
yesterday he was exciting to watch um
he's gonna have a good future
thank you joe good to talk to you
yeah thanks dan that's uh joe burl
bengal's quarterback last time we saw
him was in miami at the super bowl came
in